PROFESSOR: So,
as an aside for more
advanced students,
let's try to fill
in some mathematical
details to provide a theory
to support or interpret
the Lin-Marr hypothesis
of disinfection
kinetics having to do
with the concentration
of solutes during drying
and their effect on
deactivating viruses.
So, to put it in
mathematical terms,
if we have a certain number
of viruses Nv in a droplet,
then we'll postulate
that d Nv dt is
minus lambda v0,
the deactivation
rate per solute
virion collision,
times the volume fraction
of disinfecting solutes
we'll call phi d, which
is time dependent,
having to do with the size
of the droplet, times Nv.
The volume fraction
of disinfecting
solutes we'll write as alpha
D, a constant, times phi
s, which is the total volume
fraction of solutes present.
And that might be, for example,
the fraction of solutes
that are sodium chloride
or some other salt that
might be causing the damage
to the virus, as opposed
to the mucins or other
macromolecules that
may be present.
Then we can-- as the droplet is
shrinking with a radius R of t,
then it's simply
the volume of phi s
that is getting re-scaled
relative to the initial value,
phi 0, as R0, the
initial radius,
divided by R of t cubed.
So that's just simply the
changing of the volume.
Now let's recall
some of our results
from the past earlier
part of this chapter
having to do with Wells'
theory of evaporation.
So, if we consider
diffusion-limited droplets,
we've shown that the radius
of the droplet versus time
relative to the
initial radius R0
is square root of 1
minus t over tau e, where
tau e is the evaporation
time, R0 squared divided
by d bar, a constant with
units of diffusivity, times 1
minus RH, the relative humidity.
Now that predicts
pure liquid droplets
that shrink all the way to
nothing and evaporate away,
but, when there's
solute present, there's
a cutoff, which we've also
discussed that gives you
an equilibrium stable
size of the drop,
R equilibrium, relative to
R0, which is given by phi s0,
the solid volume fraction--
or solute volume fraction
initially divided by 1 minus
RH raised to the 1/3 power.
By writing that as square root
of 1 minus tau over tau e,
we can also define the time tau
when you reach the equilibrium
size by a diffusion-limited
evaporation process.
So that's sort of the time to
form a stable droplet nucleus.
Now let's start combining
all these equations,
and we can write what is the
volume fraction of disinfecting
solutes, phi d of t.
Well, from this equation
here, it'll be alpha d times
phi s of t, which
is phi s0, times
this ratio, R0 over R cubed.
So, using this expression for
diffusion-limited kinetics,
this would give me a 1 minus
t over tau e to the 3/2.
And, if we look at
the ultimate limit
here that they'll get from when
it's a solute, when tau goes--
or when t goes to tau,
the evaporation time,
so when you've reached
the droplet nucleus stage,
we're left with just
alpha d times 1 minus RH.
So that tells us sort of the
fraction of solutes which
are present as a function
of relative humidity,
but, also, as a function of
time, as drying is going on.
So now let's go back to
this dynamical equation.
And let's go ahead and solve it.
So this is a first-order,
separable-order differential
equation.
So what we can do is write this
as minus d Nv over lambda v0.
Nv is equal to phi d of t dt.
So we've put all
the N's on one side
and the t's on the other side.
And so we can actually then
integrate this equation.
And so the integral of dN over
N is the natural log of N.
So we can write this as
minus 1 over lambda v0
natural log of Nv
over Nv0, which
is the initial value of Nv.
And, in time, we're integrating
from the initial time
0 up to the droplet nucleus
time tau of phi d of t dt.
So, substituting our
expression right here,
we then see that we have
alpha d phi s0 times
the integral from 0 to tau
dt over 1 minus t over tau e
to the 3/2.
And we can do that integral
and get alpha d phi s0.
And then let's see.
To get the integration
variable, we
need to have a tau e here and
write that as dt over tau e.
And, doing the integral,
we would get 2 times 1
over square root of 1 minus
tau over tau e minus 1,
evaluating at the two
limits of integration,
taking into account the
integral of the-- antiderivative
of integrand there is 1
over 1 minus t over tau e
to the 1/2 power times 2.
So, putting all
this together then,
we can write the viability.
So we can write the log
of Nv over Nv0 as minus--
we have all this stuff here--
2 alpha d phi s0 lambda
v0, putting the lambda
v0 back on the other
side with the minus sign.
And then we have
times two factors.
So, first, there's
the factor, which
we know has units of time,
which is R0 squared over d bar.
So that's, essentially, kind
of a water vapor diffusion time
that comes into the
evaporation time, tau e.
So that sets the timescale here.
But then what we're
really interested in
is the relative humidity effect.
So that would be--
let's see here.
So we have this factor,
and then we also have the--
let's see.
The 1 minus RH is
coming in where?
Sorry, so, 1 over square
root of tau, this one
is from right here.
That's R over R of tau.
And R of tau is, by
definition, R equilibrium.
So it's this factor here.
So we get 1 minus RH over
phi s0 to the 1/3 minus 1.
And then we also
have this factor
of 1 minus RH that comes,
yes, from the tau e
because the tau e has this
sort of basic timescale,
but there's also a factor of
1 minus RH that I've included.
So the point of
all this theory was
to try to understand
what is the dependence
on relative humidity, which is
what I've shown here in white.
And, if you plot this
function, then what you find
is a function of
relative humidity.
Then, if you do here
log of Nv over Nv0--
so this is our relative
viability of the virus,
and the 0 here corresponds
to Nv0, the initial--
then, this white function,
what this looks like
is something, which
decays like this.
It kind of reaches
a minimum around 80
or in this range from
sort of 60 to 80,
depending on what the values
of this parameter phi s0
is in fact.
And then it goes back up again.
So, basically, we get a
shape for the dependence
of the relative humanity
that nicely matches
the experimental data and is
consistent with the hypothesis
of disinfection kinetics that
was postulated by Lin and Marr.